everyone knows Yuji itadori the main
protagonist of Jujutsu Kaizen and the
man who inhales sukura's fingers like
they were hot dogs but did you know that
Yuji is actually a human experiment with
a secret power that his mother was a
villain and that you already know his
mother even if you don't realize it yet
by the end of this video you will know
everything there is to know about yuji's
extremely dark family history and how
his entire life is all a part of a 1 000
year old villain's master plan you guys
know how this works if you enjoy our
Jutsu Kaizen content and you want to see
more in the future leave a quick like
and comment right now for that YouTube
algorithm and if you are one of the over
50 of people who watch my videos but
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a big favor and subscribe right
now we are trying to hit 2 million
subscribers so every subscription counts
now Jujutsu Kaizen has an incredible
diverse cast of magical characters with
extremely cool powers and yuji's Mom is
one of the most mysterious ones honestly
out of all the Epic sorcerer characters
it's actually hard to choose the coolest
and most mysterious one and speaking of
choosing between a diversified group of
magical characters huge thanks to this
light for sponsoring this video this
light is a turn-based mobile
role-playing game that allows you to
collect awesome and diverse characters
with Divine Powers but this is also an
ongoing series of urban myth Comics
which is super cool I love anime waifus
and mythology and this slide lets me
have both with their unique pop fantasy
style that turns gods and goddesses from
Greek Norse Chinese Egyptian and
Japanese mythology into powerful espers
build your own 5S per Squad and make
full use of the different roles of the
esper Heroes and the relationship
between their four main attributes to
optimize your team and here's the best
part in this slide you can turn on auto
battle to get resources so you can enjoy
a relaxing stress-free experience guess
what this slide is launching a new
limited time event which immerses you in
the captivating story of Xiao 2 a
classic Chinese God as a girl who
acquired Divine Powers xiaotu's fate
takes an unexpected turn when she is
caught in an eternal cycle on a radiant
summer day this epic new summer update
lets you participate in summer themed
events and earn massive Awards if you're
a fan of myths and waifus you have to
check it out for yourself download this
Slide by clicking the link in the
description or scanning the QR code on
screen if you joined this slide today
you will be directly supporting this
Channel and if you use my code fight
with Gods you will get 5 free draws and
huge in-game rewards click the link in
the description or scan the QR code
right now finally this video will
contain Jujutsu Kaizen manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you haven't
warned when we first meet Yuji itadori
at the beginning of the series we
learned that his parents are apparently
dead and because of this he was mostly
raised by his paternal grandfather
wasuke itadori unfortunately at the
start of the story yuji's grandpa is
already very ill and bedridden and we
see Yuji visiting him in the hospital
and bringing him flowers yuji's Grandpa
dies in the very first chapter of the
manga but not before imparting some
important lessons on Yuji waske tells
Yuji that he's a strong kid so he should
be using his strength to help other
people it doesn't have to be all all the
time but just whenever he can he
shouldn't expect gratitude from others
he should just help them yuji's Grandpa
also tells Yuji to make sure that when
it's his time to go he will be
surrounded by other people who care
about him he advises his grandson not to
end up like him and then he passes away
even though yuji's Grandpa waske only
appears briefly in the first chapter of
the story and then dies Yuji does take
his advice to heart and his Grandpa's
words have a significant impact on his
future decisions however there is one
part of the conversation between Yuji
and his grandpa in the very first
chapter that is often overlooked because
of how quickly it goes by at the very
beginning of their conversation inside
of Vasquez hospital room yuji's Grandpa
tells Yuji that he has some final words
for him and that these words are about
yuji's parents but Yuji cuts his grandpa
off he says stop I don't care waske
tries to talk about yuji's parents again
but Yuji interrupts him again telling
him to stop trying to act cool before he
dies and to just be his usual self as it
turns out the truth about yuji's parents
is far darker and far more messed up
than any of us could have imagined in
that early part of the story and I
really wish that Yuji let his grandpa
speak about that specific topic to be
fair though the fact that the topic of
yuji's parents was brought up but then
wasn't elaborated on made the subject
even more intriguing and it foreshadowed
the craziness that was about to follow
now at the beginning of the story we
learned right away that Yuji is
unusually strong fast and athletic so
much so that he absolutely smokes his
Athletics Club supervisor Mr Takagi in a
shot put competition he also
demonstrates strength and speed that are
far above what a normal human should be
able to do when he helps megumi fight
the curses inside his school and also
when he actually eats one of sukuna's
fingers and instead of dying he is able
to become a vessel for sukuna not only
that but Yuji is able to actually
suppress sukuna inside of him thereby
preventing the king of curses from just
taking over his body at will in fact
even after consuming multiple fingers
that belonged to sukuna Yuji is still
able to mostly control the monster
inside of him Gojo notes that a person
with such a phenomenal ability appears
only once in every thousand years but
why is Yuji so special why is he so
unusually strong fast and athletic and
why is he able to handle becoming a
vessel for sukuna while successfully
suppressing and controlling the most
powerful cursed Spirit of all time it's
not just some Cosmic coincidence it all
goes back to the dark truth about yuji's
parents and this is exactly what yuji's
Grandpa wanted to talk to him about
before Yuji interrupted him to be clear
the full story behind yuji's family
history is still shrouded in mystery but
the few reveals that we do have are
absolutely shocking in chapter
143 we got a flashback that actually
showed yuji's mom and dad for the first
time and this quick two-page story was
so crazy that I had to immediately do a
double take when I first read it I could
not believe what I just saw and I had to
read it again in the flashback we see
yuji's Dad Jin itadori holding a baby
Yuji in his arms and talking to yuji's
Grandpa waske waske is trying to talk to
his son about that woman but yuji's Dad
says that if the conversation is about
her he's just gonna leave waske says to
his son Jin you can live your life
however you like but give up on that
woman you'll die jyn replies by saying
don't talk about such things in front of
Yuji they say babies remember more than
we think a clearly agitated waskit
persists he says I know you wanted a
child and that didn't happen with cowdy
but her death was and then he is
interrupted by a woman who simply says
father-in-law what are you talking about
this one woman is presumably yuji's
mother because she calls yuji's Grandpa
father-in-law and here's the crazy part
this woman has a clearly visible scar on
her forehead the same type of Scar that
ghetto has after he dies and his body is
essentially hijacked by the ancient evil
Sorcerer kenjaku And that is it that is
all we get in the flashback it's very
brief but there is a lot that we can
extrapolate from this quick conversation
wasuke had said that Jin always wanted
to have a child with a woman named cowdy
but it didn't happen because she died we
didn't get the details of her death
because wasuke was cut off but that was
the implication at some point cloudy
died before having children and yet here
she was now interrupting the
conversation by referring to wasuke as
her father-in-law and she has that scar
unless we're being deliberately misled
by the author to me this can only mean
one thing yuji's father Jin was in love
with a woman named cowdy and he wanted
to have a family with her unfortunately
at some point she died Jin simply
couldn't give up on kauri and his dream
of being with her and having a family
with her so he seems to have accepted
some sort of deal with the devil or
rather a deal with kanjaku kanjaku was
able to bring kaori itadori back to life
by possessing her body and by doing this
Jin and kauri were able to produce a
child Yuji but while this child might
biologically belong to Jin and cowdy
cowdy is clearly not herself anymore she
was replaced by kenjaku now it's
possible that Jin didn't realize what
was really happening maybe kenjaku
claimed that he could save kauri but it
didn't reveal how exactly he would do it
so maybe jyn thinks that the real coyote
is still in there and he doesn't realize
that her body is being possessed by
kanjaku but from the way that yuji's
Grandpa was talking it seems that he
knew that something was deeply wrong
here waske knew that cowdy died and he
knew that if Jin continued to associate
with whatever county has become he would
also die it's still not clear what Jin's
true motivations and intentions were
here was he just a desperate man in
denial who was pretending that his wife
was back even though it was actually
kenjaku or did he know exactly what was
going on but he chose to live with it
because he wanted to have a child with
coyote and he was willing to do anything
for the illusion of having her back fun
fact but even though we never saw yuji's
mom using Jujutsu sorcery we do have a
good idea what her cursed technique was
in chapter 208 kenjaku reveals that
kauri possessed a technique called
anti-gravity system and even after
kenjaku left Coyote's body he retained
the ability to use her technique this
technique allows the user to negate
gravity and the cursed technique
reversal of this power allows the user
to amplify the gravitational all around
them but what was kenjaku's motivation
in all of this why would this 1 000 year
old sorcerer whose grandiose goal is to
usher in a new golden age of Jujutsu
sorcery by using cursed energy to force
Humanity to evolve go through all the
trouble of becoming yuji's Mom
apparently Jin and kauri did not have
children before she died so presumably
kenjaku had to get pregnant while in
caudi's body be pregnant for nine months
and then literally give birth to Yuji
like that is a pretty big commitment so
what possessed kanjaku to do this the
answer to this question is extremely
dark and it leads us to the disturbing
Revelation that Yuji is one of kenjaku's
human experiments the fact that Yuji has
superhuman strength speed and
athleticism the fact that he was able to
consume sukuna's fingers and suppress
sukuna inside of him and the fact that
he was able to improve his Jujutsu
sorcery so quickly this was not some
Cosmic coincidence this was all a part
of kenjaku's master plan so who is
Kendra and what has he or she been up to
for the past 1 000 years
kenjaku is currently possessing ghetto's
body so I will refer to him as he but we
don't actually know what kenjaku's
original gender was kanjaku's past dates
back a thousand years all the way back
to the Golden Age of Jujutsu sorcery the
heian period of Japanese history this
makes kanjaku a contemporary of ryom and
sukuna and many other overpowered
Sorcerers and curse users kanjaku has
managed to stay alive for this long due
to his incredibly rare and incredibly
creepy innate technique this technique
enables kanjaku to essentially possess
the body of another person including the
body of a dead person by somehow
transplanting his own brain into the
head of his host The Telltale sign of
kenjaku's presence within a body is the
long scar that runs horizontally around
the person's forehead the same scar that
we saw in the body of sugru ghetto and
kauri itadori as well as the bodies of
other people that Kendrick possessed
throughout history including of course
the infamous noritoshi kamo when kanjaku
enters someone's body he is able to
access their cursed energy as well as
their innate cursed techniques he even
retains the host's memories allowing him
to seamlessly usurp the host's entire
life in fact Kendrick was able to mimic
his host's presence so well that even
Gojo's six eyes can't detect him as an
imposter as I said upon possessing a
body kanjaku retains the host's body's
unique cursed energy so it's hard to
track it if that wasn't enough kanjaku
has access to not only his current host
bodies in a technique but he is even
able to use the cursed techniques of the
people he had possessed in the past such
as cowori needless to say this is an
extremely overpowered ability although
there does appear to be some limit to
how many techniques and how much
information in general his brain can
retain without overloading and if
everything you heard so far isn't creepy
enough kanjaku has the ability to
literally take off the upper part of his
host's body's head in order to reveal
feel his real brain believe it or not
his real brain the one he transplants
into the host bodies actually has teeth
and it looks like it is smiling in order
to decipher the dark intentions that
drove kenjaku to literally become yuji's
mother we have to go back some 150 years
to the Meiji period in kenjaku's actions
while he was possessing the body of
noritoshi Kamal the man whom Sorcerers
of the modern era are referred to as the
evilest Jutsu sorcerer in history
noritoshi was a member of The prominent
kamo family and he had been in charge of
a temple inside the temple he conducted
terrifying experiments with human and
cursed Spirit hybrids noritoshi came
across a woman who was able to give
birth to human cursed Spirit hybrids and
he imprisoned her and conducted many
experiments on her these experiments led
to the creation of the cursed womb death
paintings nine special grade cursed
objects that were created by mixing the
blood of both a human and a cursed
Spirit these cursed objects have three
parents in total the woman who gave
birth to them the cursed Spirit who
fathered them and noritoshikamu AKA
kanjaku who mixed his own blood into the
cursed wombs imbuing all of them with
the inherited technique of the kamo
family blood manipulation these objects
were eventually found by Jujutsu
Sorcerers and they were kept securely
inside Jujutsu high for many decades but
during the Goodwill event villain
invasion mahito was able to steal all of
them and deliver them to kanjaku soon
after that three of the nine cursed
wombs were incarnated into flesh and
blood vessels including Esso kechizu and
the chosol you will be familiar with
these guys from the final few episodes
of season 1 of the Jujutsu Kaizen anime
but do you want to know the craziest
part although Esso and catches who are
killed quickly after being introduced
chosol survives and he ends up being a
pretty important character in the later
arcs of the story what's more he
eventually allies himself with Yuji and
the sorcerers against kenjaku and the
villains not only that but he comes to
view Yuji itadori as one of his brothers
I because they share a common parent
kenjaku kanjaku helped to create the
nine cursed wombs while he was
possessing the body of noritoshikamu and
he also birthed Yuji itadori when he was
possessing the body of his mother cowdy
we know that kanjaku created the nine
cursed wombs as part of a ghoulish human
experiment designed to create human and
cursed Spirit hybrids so why did he
become kauri itadori and go through all
the trouble of giving birth to Yuji my
guess is that his reason for creating
Yuji was very similar to his reason for
creating the cursed wounds Yuji is a
human experiment a creature created for
the specific purpose of furthering
kenjaku's greatest ambition the forced
evolution of humanity through cursed
energy I believe that Yuji is just as
much of a human experiment as choso and
the nine cursed wombs and I believe
there is a dark power inside of him that
we are not yet aware of but that will be
revealed as the story progresses and as
we learn more information about yuji's
dark family history it is likely that
Yuji is also some sort of hybrid between
a flesh and blood human and a cursed
Spirit but since he was created over a
hundred years after the cursed wombs
it's likely that kanjaku made
improvements in his experimentation
techniques during that time and so Yuji
is a more sophisticated model when
compared to the nine cursed wombs right
now in the Jujutsu Kaizen story Gojo has
taken center stage and Yuji is kind of
chilling on the sidelines and as of the
making of this video This is actually
the case in both the Kaizen anime and
manga but there is a reason why our
story started with Yuji itadori there is
a reason why the mystery of his parents
has been teased since the very first
chapter and you better believe that
there is more to Yuji than meets the eye
when the full story of his father and
mother is revealed the Dark Truth is
going to shock everyone
what do you guys think is Yuji a human
experiment and some sort of
sophisticated human and cursed Spirit
hybrid if I were to guess I would say
that kanjaku manipulated yuji's father
Jin into creating Yuji although Jin may
not have been even aware of kanjaku's
true intentions perhaps kanjaku used
Jin's immense grief over the loss of his
wife to somehow incarnate a curse inside
of baby Yuji something slightly
reminiscent of the Utah and Rika
situation but also different what will
be the final truth about yuji's mother
and father what will yuji's ultimate
power be definitely share your feedback
down in the comments I really want to
hear all your best theories on the
secret origins of Yuji itadori if you're
looking for an epic jiu Jutsu Kaizen
video to watch next check out my video
on Gojo and why he has the power to
destroy all of humanity if you enjoyed
this video you can leave a like to let
me know and if you're one of the over 50
of people who watch my videos but have
and taking the time to subscribe yet
help me reach that Incredible 2 million
by subscribing right now thanks again to
this slide for sponsoring this video
check them out right now Link in the
description